hey everybody its Joshua fields Millburn
we're about to dive into another live
episode of the minimalist podcast one
thing really quick though we are getting
ready to head over to Australia and New
Zealand and tickets go on sale this week
you can head on over to the minimalists
comm make sure you're on our email list
and you'll be the first to know or if
you're a patreon supporter over at
patreon.com slash the minimalist you'll
have access to the presale tickets to
those events we're going to be in
Australia and New Zealand we're doing
four stops in March of 2018 we hope to
see you over there
all right let's dive into this live a
version of the minimalist podcast
enjoy
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'd
be fine without him we've discovered
that song and really strange where I was
on the subway in New York and Peter did
send us a tweet said I really think
you'll like this message and we had
nowhere to use the song so I'm like hey
this is our new official theme song but
this was years before we had a podcast
or anything we could use it for so now
we now we get to use Peter song
repeatedly
yeah every day Peter Doran is very
talented Irish musician anyway hey yo
let's record a podcast live from the
University of Calgary
welcome to the minimalist podcast we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Melbourne and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and we are live in Calgary
that is great thank you for being here
uh we usually take phone calls but
instead we have a microphone set up
right over there I believe there may be
some people lined up Ryan last night
after the event we were doing like the
book signing line and hug line and all
that fun stuff this guy came up to me
and he said hey man this is my favorite
call I've ever been in which which tells
me a few things about this man he's
tried out several cults before before
now I'm very thankful he's still alive
but but then also that he thought this
was a cult and well it is this will be
passing out kool-aid later we have those
like white Nikes for sale on the lobby
no I I just want to assure you for those
of you who were driving here tonight
this is not a cult we are not trying to
convert you to minimalism but we do have
a few answers and we hope to give you a
few answers so if you wouldn't mind tell
us what your name is where you're from
and what your question is in that order
hi howdy my name is Keeley Dunn I'm
actually your local community leader Oh
Keeley it's so nice to meet you yes so
just just before we get to all the great
questions that we've got quite a lineup
going I just wanted to let you all know
that we do have a local chapter that it
would be really awesome for you all to
join who here is actually already in the
group
oh wow very cool nice so for the people
who don't know Keeley given little
synopsis of what minimalist org is in
Calgary so what we do is just bring the
local people together we have our little
meetups in our discussions and we try to
just bring to Calgary the local flavor
of what Ryan and Josh are talking about
worldwide so so so for those of you
listen to this at home and you're like
what the hell are they talking about
local group
it's the local cult no it's well in 2014
Ryan and I went on this crazy hundred
city tour it was we basically donated
ten months of her life to do 119
different events in 100 cities eight
different countries but people before
that they would come up to us and say
hey it's great that you're here for an
evening but you're leaving how do I
connect with open-minded people locally
and I would just sort of stare at them
and blink a few times because I didn't
have a good answer I'm like I don't know
do they have OkCupid here which
apparently was not the right answer but
so we we created something called
minimalist org and it's free local
meetup groups in a hundred different
cities many cities are thriving and they
have hundreds of members and what that
does it takes you to this Facebook group
page and they typically meet once a
month sometimes more frequently and so
if you want to connect with open minded
people who are supportive and you could
talk about decluttering and minimalism
if you want but I've noticed that a lot
of people are talking about health and
relationships and their career and
advice and giving advice and really it's
being supportive and being supported by
open-minded people they're not
necessarily like-minded they might have
different beliefs from you they may have
I mean Ryan and I are this way too we're
not like-minded we're we're both
open-minded you know we we we have
radically different personalities we
have different religious beliefs
different political beliefs we even
voted for two different people in the
last election
hey just so you guys know there's more
than two options in the United States
see about our country doesn't know that
anyway yeah so we sort of just left
those behind we don't want anything from
you we don't require an email address or
anything to sign up we just want to
leave that behind and say hey if you
want to connect with other people
there's a great way to do it and thank
you for being the community leader here
that is so valuable and so helpful for a
lot of people real problems so
minimalist org forward slash Calgary
come visit it's a great group really
good-looking lots of fun and kill you do
such an awesome job thank you very much
yeah
[Applause]
hi hi Josh hi Ryan
hello what's your name my name is Aisha
I am originally from Ottawa and I just
moved to Calgary a couple years ago
welcome I went to check out that group I
quickly want to thank you guys just
before I get into my question for what
she do and how to make minimalism so
relevant and like applicable to modern
day life
I was rated as a Muslim and like
minimalism is something that I was
always taught through my life like
through Scripture and stuff like that
but no one around me really practiced it
like it wasn't no one really exemplified
it for me so when I discovered you guys
like it was really awesome because you
just made it so like easy and I think my
favorite quote from you guys from your
podcast and you say like no matter what
DD worship they all want you to lead a
meaningful life and I think that's just
great I really want to thank you for
that so my question is about clothing I
was really lucky to find your
documentary just after moving here and I
didn't bring anything with me just a few
suitcases of clothes so it was really
easy for me to let go so I just wrote my
question down so don't go off too much
so ever since adopting minimalism my
closet is automatically reduced by I'm
finding it difficult to keep it that way
unlike my furniture and other things
around the house which serve a specific
purpose are fine clothing to be more
about self-expression and aesthetic I
like the idea of only owning a few well
tailored items but I find myself
constantly distract distracted by other
people's styles I'm constantly
dissatisfied with the clothing I have
and I'm always stressing out about
looking trendy and copying my icons and
what they wear so I'm wondering if you
have any tips on how to find your own
style and be satisfied with it and to
kind of like build these blinders and to
stop being so dissatisfied by the
infinite possibilities of outfits that
are constantly marketed to us it's
simple you just pick one outfit and you
just wear that I love black I love black
and I knows a lot you could spice up
with a good spice it up with laces and
what some purple socks
no that's that's a that's a great
question um because yeah the only reason
why I wear one outfit is because like
this is it's like a very classic style
outfit and it's what I look and feel
best in if I could pull off some like
really cool like skinny jeans I would
but that's just I just can't
in fact we were worried today we were we
were eating at that cafe and the guy
next door came out said hey minimalist
guys by the way that's that's our level
of celebrity it's always hey aren't you
that minimalist guy and he was like
dressed so dapper he had red loafers he
had red loafers and it looked really
good he had this like small Paisley
shirt on he was like like starched and
you know we're just rolled there out of
bed from Vancouver and yeah yeah and and
we were like man I wish I could pull
that off and I think I think maybe and
correct me if I'm wrong here Ryan but
but the thing that you just you touched
on is the thing that I feel most
comfortable because you could wear what
he was wearing but it wouldn't feel good
to you
is that accurate yeah that's a hundred
percent true that's I mean that's
exactly what I'm saying is like when you
will even before I say you know about
looking at other styles and and not
going out of your way just to get
something that's in vogue just for the
fact that it's in vogue I would really
encourage you like stop comparing
yourself to other people
yes we live in in what we did live for
the last five years of Montana we're
moving this month but and and I've gone
to a lot of saunas with American Indian
tribes and one thing that I've learned
from that at different conversations is
that they often view comparison as a
mental illness and in one Singh Moore is
also a part of that illness right yeah
yeah it's it's you're never gonna be
100% in vogue no one here ever will and
in the fashion companies in the
celebrities they they stack it that way
on purpose so if you're always trying to
keep up with the latest trend well
you're never actually gonna be there
because there's always gonna be a new
trend around the corner so yeah I would
I would just say like yes fine find some
things that are your favorite things
that you look really really good in and
your friends and family like the people
who love you the people who really care
about you and want you to be happy
they're not gonna care what you wear and
if you are hanging out with people who
are judging your clothing then I would
just ask you to reconsider who you spend
most of your time with yeah if I were to
add to that I when you're talking about
influences and you're being influenced
by these sort of external and usually it
has to do with something that's on a
glowing screen I'm assuming right
television or Instagram or yeah I mean
the the ads there are fairly pernicious
because they're so good
yeah people make a living out of making
you want to buy their clothes out of
making you want to buy the latest
fashion so yeah certainly something like
that would be super influence
influential so so we used to have two
seasons in North America warm and cold
and that's what we dressed for right we
put away the winter clothes and get out
the summer clothes and have some sort of
variation of that and the in between
seasons we now thanks to fast fashion
have 52
shopping seasons a year you'll never
keep up so keep that in mind but I also
see it as well I can tell you like there
are a few TV shows i watch where la
there's a TV show that I will binge
watch sometimes called ray Donovan and
it is it's like typical pop sort of show
and it's a fairly good show but he is
dressed to the nines but really like
understated I'm like oh man maybe I
should wear a suit every day maybe I
should have a piece of cloth around my
neck and so what I've learned is when I
rephrase it like that like maybe I
should wear a stuffy jacket like wait a
minute no that's not that that's not
necessary and so for me I agree with
Ryan has to be comfortable in it but
here are a few tips for you it to help
out one is you want to limit yourself
90% of you have purchased a article of
clothing within the last month 50% of
you within the last week possibly today
I'm not judging you for that it it
happens I actually I bought some
underwear recently so I fall into that
category as well
hypocrite yeah it was true you know you
can't wear underwear and be a minimalist
no and what what I've learned is
sometimes when you go to our events some
of the the best-dressed people have done
something called Project 333 some you
all are familiar with that yeah I would
look at them and see what their wardrobe
looks like because it's probably the
best in here and here's why
III think that limitations breed
creativity but they also bring forward
your favorite things you probably have
something in your closet that you don't
absolutely enjoy wearing but you're
holding on to it just in case for me I
used to weigh 80 pounds more than I
weigh now so I had several tubs in my
basement of clothes just in case I got
fat again
and so it's a horrible backup plan right
why didn't you stop me no I I think
having limitations like that so check
out project 333 it's just the
minimalists comm slash Cortney for those
of you listening at home we'll put a
link to that in the show notes or
podcast Sean well and I think that
having certain limitations like that
here's another thing don't purchase
something for X number of days for me I
found that five months was a really good
sweet spot and you will experience some
deprivation there it's gonna be short
term deprivation but all of a sudden
it'll help you refocus your appreciation
a for what you have but B for what you
need and if you do that four or five
months I'd try for five months and and
it'll reshift
what you focus on I'll give you one last
tip before I went to the outfit I would
in my closet you know get something put
it on and every time I had this feeling
of like yeah this looks ok but if I
didn't love it like it was it was going
in the donate box so if you have a ton
of clothes which it sounds like you have
enough it may be a little bit more I
would highly recommend using that rule
if you put it on and you look in the
mirror and you don't feel outstanding
then then get rid of it what there's no
reason to hold on to that anyway we're
gonna go back and forth all night cuz I
got one more thing for you
in 2011 I one of the first interviews I
ever did with some some blog journalists
reached out to us and said they want to
know like what are your three favorite
items that you own and I'm like [ __ ]
they're not they're kind of missing the
point of the minimalism thing but okay
it's true that I do get immense value
from the things I have I get far more
value from the few items that I kept
right and so the clothes I have I
actually do get far more value from them
but the way they worded is like what
items do you love oh my oh there are
some things that I loved I had a
favorite pair of shoes I had a favorite
like dress shirt and I had a favorite
pair of jeans and I had to ask myself
why don't I love these things well why
am I so attached to them and so here's
another experiment you may want to try
if you're brave enough I said you know
here are my three favorite things and
with that journalist and I'd like to
give these away to someone who could use
them get him rid of my favorite things
help me let go of the attachment to any
of the other things because here's the
other cool thing is I had other shirts
that stepped up and became my favorite
shirt or my favorite shoes or favorite
pair of pants and thus I was no longer
as attached to my quote favorite things
thank you
[Applause]
hi Josh hi Ryan my name is Emily howdy
actually from Spokane Washington my
husband and I drove up here this week oh
wow
welcome thank you for making the drive
that is Spokane is the Dayton Ohio of
the North West and we missed you guys
when you were in Spokane it was great
yeah yeah that's what I've heard so we
made the drive up here Josh I wanted to
tell you really quickly that I really
appreciate in your writings whenever
you're telling people that they can be
passionate about anything that there's
even people passionate about accounting
because we're both accounting students
and we love accounting so we're those
people it's true we have an accountant
who is passionate about accounting I
don't understand it but I don't
understand people we're passionate about
horseback riding either they but I I get
that you all right and I think it's
great Bravo thank you what advice you
have for people sitting here tonight
sometimes it seems like we're not able
to make drastic changes in our life
until something catastrophic happens for
you Josh it was losing your mom and your
divorce Ryan it sounds like you were
maybe getting close to rock bottom with
the drug abuse and the alcohol abuse I
don't think she intended that to be
funny but it was and it's pretty
accurate and so for people who are
sitting here thinking that well I'm
relatively happy my life isn't falling
apart around me what advice would you
have for those people why now is the
time to take action and drastically
change their lives yeah I think I think
the status quo is a bit of a problem
because until those two events I didn't
really realize how discontented I was it
was this low-level
discontent this anxiety this constant
stress this I was living someone else's
ideal life but it wasn't my ideal life
and and for me when my mom died my
marriage ended it was
just sort of this this shift in focus
like wow what what is truly important to
me and and what have I've been focused
on I didn't I was sort of going with the
flow for a long time but but the problem
is when you go with the flow of entry
you end up at the rapids and if you
don't have a plan once you get there
man you're and for a world of hurt and
and so I think that now minimalist was
sort of the way that I'm able to paddle
against the current right and like Ryan
was talking about earlier in his talk
when he said it's not a perfect life
it's not an easy life in fact it's the
opposite of the easier I simple isn't
easy it's well curated it's intentional
it's deliberate it's in a weird way it's
sort of the obverse side of that that
coin but when I look at when I look at
that old life my problem there is that I
was too comfortable I actually wasn't
experienced enough pain or I didn't
associate enough pleasure with making
the change because making the change is
actually more painful than staying where
you are me walking away from the
corporate world wasn't just walking away
from the corporate world it was spending
over two years on the tightest budget
you can possibly imagine to pay off an
immense amount of debt that's really
painful when you're used to spending a
couple hundred thousand dollars a year
which I cringe just saying that now the
but but it allows me to to look back at
that and say okay that was a temporary
pain but I knew what was around the bin
I knew what the outcome was and I was
able to associate enough pleasure with
what that outcome was and then also
associated enough pain with what this
status quo is right now and and what are
those pain points for you it might be
health it might be finances for me it
was both of those things finances were
out of control I even I made really good
money but I spent even better money and
so I had massive amounts of debt and
that's that's painful because it kept me
tethered to this lifestyle that wasn't
bringing me meaning or purpose or
fulfillment so associated of pain with
what's going on now if you want to make
it
and enough pleasure with what it looks
like like what's that ideal place not
the perfect place what's the ideal place
because you're never gonna get there by
the way you're still gonna have problems
they're just gonna be better problems
yeah the comfort the comfort zone is
it's a it's it's a dangerous place to be
I mean for me I was comfortable I mean
man you drink enough and do enough drugs
like you're comfortable there's no doubt
about it first someone go yeah
maybe back in the alley after the show
I'm kidding don't do that no III think
for me I was about to hit rock bottom
and it wasn't about having the a
traumatic event happen you know what
happened to Josh I think it was way more
traumatizing than what I went through I
mean I got to a point where man I was
everyone I knew like all my friends who
were doing drugs they like eventually
transition to heroin
and I remember at a certain point like
I'm going through withdrawal and I can't
find my drugs and alcohol isn't doing it
and I'm like well everyone else is doing
arawa but like as soon as I even started
to have that thought I was like okay
dude would it be fair to say you late
you saw rock bottom before you got there
yeah yeah like I saw a little glimpse of
it well because I saw their lives and
I'll tell you like now I can now on two
hands are three hands so take three
hands now yes that's a third hand yes
and yeah that I know people of how many
people I know who have overdosed on
heroin and a lot of them have passed
away unfortunately and yes I do think
that having a traumatic experience or or
getting close to rock-bottom certainly
can or you know doesn't a lot of cases
give
some leverage to really make major life
changes but you know if I could talk to
my you know 25 year old self I would I
would just really try and instill on
that person so I guess the same thing
I'm trying you know I would try to
instill on someone who's in that comfort
zone but isn't happy I would really try
to instill that hey if you're not happy
with what you're doing it can only get
worse so start to make a change now or
really regret later not instilling that
change and the other thing too is I mean
you know for someone who's in that state
I would say look at your priorities what
are your priorities because if you were
to ask my 25 year old stuff like hey
Ryan what are your priorities I would
have had great answers I don't like what
my health is my priorities if I'm not
healthy what do I have in my
relationships well of course you know
the top five people you hang around and
who your role models are that's that
that's that's who you are as a person
and you know it got to be passionate
about something and you know you got to
contribute but when I really look at who
I was at 25 I wasn't doing or focusing
on any of those things and I realized
that oh yeah my my priorities they
aren't what I say they are it's what I
actually do so for anyone out there who
is in this comfort zone but sees
themselves or feels themselves getting
to this unhappy state I would say write
down what your priorities are get clear
on what it is you want to do with your
life and where is the least like if you
were to look at those priorities as
buckets of water or sand like where is
the least full bucket and start there
and I'll tell you like when you do start
focusing on your priorities it's it is
difficult and it there is some drudgery
that goes along with with it but once
you actually fill those buckets the
feeling that one gets it's it's so much
better than comfort show me your
calendar I'll show you your priorities
before we move on to the next little
little segment here if
you're listening to this at home and you
have a comment or tip for anyone who
asks a question today you can call up
leave this voicemail for zero six two
one nine seven eight three nine where
air our favorite comments and tips on a
future episode you can also send a voice
memo right from your phone now those you
sound pretty good if you just go to
podcast at the minimalists comm it's
always really helpful if you write it
down first because brevity is is the
soul of wit or brevity is wit I suppose
yeah so so yeah it'd give us a comment
tip it's really my favorite segment of
our podcast is when we stop talking and
other people like because that's one of
the reasons we go on the road right now
is to listen to the questions in person
it's so much different from just getting
an answering machine it's also a reason
we're building this podcast studio so we
can do live callers interact with people
on the air live and you get a lot more
out of that but getting tips from other
people who you know they have it more
figured out than we do in particular
instances with the technology or
scanning or relationships or whatever I
get some of the best tips I'm able to
sort of steal and reuse and repackage
for these for our events but it's it's
listening so please call in we'll we
will air your comments on the future
episode Ryan what time is it it is time
for our hashtag ask the minimalists
lightning round where we usually answer
questions from social media that'd be
weird if we got on our cell phones right
now and started answering questions we
are on Twitter and Instagram and
Facebook at the minimalists and we
usually take this round to answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response something
pithy we call them minimal Maxim's and
but we're just maunder on a bid now
until we can figure out something
tweetable for you by the way jessica
lynn williams runs all of our social
media and she live tweets from these
things you can check our our Twitter
account and you go over there you can
use the hashtag les is now and you can
check that as well you can also post any
of your pictures from tonight using that
hashtag will repost some of our
favorites but if you want to see some of
the live tweeting from some of the pithy
or obnoxious answers that we give
tonight ladies and gentlemen jessica
lynn williams give her a round of
applause
[Applause]
you can find all of these pithy minimal
Maxim's she runs a side website for us
called minimal Maxim's comm which we
just started recently and you just
refresh it it's a new quote every single
time and so a lot of people we've been
told are putting it as their sort of
what's that called on the main page of
your browser the homepage now screen
saver homepage I like internets you're
supposed to be the one with a good
memory was cold but yeah so you can put
that as your homepage and there's a
different quote every every time you
pull it up it refreshes middle minimal
Maxim's com
but what is your name and your question
and we'll do our best to give you
something pithy eventually I'm Cameron
and I'm from Calgary so this should be
really easy probably like six words
favorite ski resort you've been to and
last podcast you listening to Josh
that's thank God he gave you a Part B
question because Mellie has been
snowboarding once in his life and I took
him in Ohio and like I mean compared to
here it it was like the first you know
beginner Hill but it was like it was a
bunny hole compared to like anything
around here it was less than a bunny I
almost I almost killed Josh I didn't
mean to but yeah it was it was pretty
funny like I don't know if you've ever
been with someone snow boring for the
first time but he was totally doing the
lake down the hill just going in 360s
and I was like man he really knows what
he's doing until he like ate it and
anyway I couldn't find the brakes what's
your favorite place to go skiing
snowboarding sunshine it's over a Banff
goddamnit Canada you you kill Montana
when it comes to scenery go to the polar
peak in Fernie
you like it what's that polar peak in
Fernie it's okay
and I haven't been a Whistler yet what
you hear is pretty awesome too but yeah
I was like really lucky back in right
before our tour January 2014 to go to
its I think it's Sunshine Village am I
right on that yeah okay
yeah and mountains for days oh my
goodness like you get to the top of a
mountain in Montana like it is gorgeous
I mean glacier is amazing if you haven't
been to Montana like I would totally
recommend it it's I mean it's really
it's like did you just go go south few
hours it's right there
whitefish is unbelievable people are
great down there yeah but uh man like
BAMF just is it's a whole other level of
beauty podcasts I aspire to be a
conversationalist like Joe Rogan is one
day I was just listening to his podcast
he is the Mozart of podcasting I think
he's a really talented stand-up comedian
he's he's sort of this autodidact who is
a renaissance man in so many ways but he
stumbled into this thing called
podcasting a long time ago and he is a
amazing conversationalist he can have a
a physicist on one day and a guy who
beats up people for a living the next
day and he can have an equally coherent
conversation with both of them and we
don't do interviews on our podcast
mainly because it terrifies me and so
Ryan and I just have conversations we're
just sort of practicing right now we
just interview each other every single
podcast so yeah I mean I think I think
that's for me the only person who can
get me listen to a three-hour podcast is
is probably Joe Rogan thanks guys thank
you for the question Thanks
sorry nothing pithy there what Joe Rogan
is the Mozart of podcasting that's pithy
names Christine I'm from Hamilton
originally but I moved to Calgary a few
years ago which is probably why yes he's
actually from Calgary his most people
from Calgary are live in Calgary aren't
from Calgary it seems we did a tour stop
in Hamilton three years ago it was like
this is our first legit tour we've been
on eight tours in seven years and it was
on a porch of a restaurant I recall
dude when people sat on the porch cuz
like just more people showed up than
what we had expected yeah that the porch
seated 14 and it was humble it was
unbelievable it was it was like 50 I
remember the guy who owned the place he
went as people were packing onto the
porch because it was on the second level
he like went downstairs he was like
looking to see if it was gonna give away
it was nerve-wracking talk I have ever
given it was excellent and and and
everything was fine and actually he
learned like I got a really really
strong porch what's your question my
question is about gifting and so you've
talked about it in previous podcast but
I'm just wondering about people who like
their language of love is about gifting
so the gift as a way to show how they
care about you but if you don't want
those gifts because your house is
already full of stuff where you want to
prefer experiences how do you have that
conversation with people how do you even
if you kind of already had it like meet
what's maybe the best way to approach it
you don't want to take away from how
they're showing they care but do you
wanna have a mock conversation yeah I
got my conversation I was my grandma
about the the paperweight she gave me
well let's let's let's have to but
that's a that's a good one but let's
let's listen yes have a mock
conversation but let's do it back and
forth because as you all know who
listened to the podcast I am the voice
of reason
and Ryan is the voice of sanity probably
let's go with compassion compassion okay
voice of compassion yeah yeah so so I'm
a bit more draconian so here's what I
pithy answer for you then we'll have a
conversation
my tweetable answer is if gift-giving is
a love language then pig latin is a
Romance language all right so in what we
can talk about that but thanks this will
give me time to think of a pet the
answer so let's let's talk about it um
here's the gift er here you're the gift
er I'm giving you something yeah Ryan
man it's it's Christmas and I got to
leave Christmas I really do actually I
freaking love Christmas I got you this
everybody's nice look how nice he's
beating me right now and he's just
pretending it's Christmas look just go
ahead and open these oh wow thank you
for this gift man cuff links that's
great did you like the wrapping paper I
put the wrapping paper was great man I
can I can tell that you really went out
of your way man I even have my initials
on them yeah it's really amazing yeah
wow you embroidered them wow that's
amazing man thank you so much for this
thoughtful thoughtful gift you're
welcome
hey when do you think you're gonna wear
them well here I gotta be honest with
you I I really love you man and I know
how much you love me
I can tell by this gift that you gave me
and then I just throw them in the trash
no and I can tell how much you love me
by this gift man I got to be honest with
you I'm I'm not really much of a
cufflink we're but you know what I know
someone with the same exact initials who
does wear cufflinks really yeah I'm
probably never gonna use these it it is
it cool with you if I like give these to
my friend Ryan nibble knock Adiemus you
have a friend named Ryan nibble knock a
diva I do all right
[Laughter]
all right so let's let's reverse it here
so hey Ryan my birthday was just this
past summer right in June 29th
I turned 36 I'm gonna be turning 37 next
June and let's talk about birthday gifts
[ __ ] were old man oh yes birthday guess
um yeah now last year I've gotta tell
you man that George Foreman grill did
you use that I well what do you mean by
used it
I put it on my counter okay yeah and
well next year I'm turning 37 yeah and
you know how about this I'm certainly
not gonna tell you not to get gifts for
me because I know for you that
gift-giving is a love language and I
what I really know by that I know that
you don't mean that gift-giving is an
actual love language in the sense that
giving a physical gift what you want to
do by gift-giving is you're trying to
add value to my life and I really
appreciate that and let me tell you I
made this list the spreadsheet of all of
the ways that you could add value to my
life via experiences now you'll notice
the first one here says leave me alone
for a week I hope that helped next
question nope so here's the honest thing
about that like that gift-giving can be
a love language in the sense that adding
value as a love language not be gifting
of a physical good that is one way to
try to add value to someone else's life
but the truth is we're so steeped in
consumerism we don't need any more [ __ ]
and so there are so many better ways to
add value to someone's life and you have
to figure out how can I help argument
their experience and it could be via a a
normal experience that you may have with
them concert tickets I'm sure some of
you have brought significant others or
friends tonight to this where they're
like I have no idea what I'm getting
into
and but I know it's gonna be important
for the person for me to be there and
support them and so sometimes it's just
showing up and supporting them for
something you may not want to go to and
finding a way to improve their life via
experiences or if you absolutely have to
give a physical thing I find consumables
are great like a great bag of coffee
bottle of wine something like that yeah
I think Josh and I'll probably differ a
little bit on this
I mean gift gift-giving maybe like I
feel like maybe it could be a love
language I mean someone wrote a book on
it it's got to be true right
but at the end of the day like if and
I'm not I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
give it to you straight if you are
someone who gift-giving is your love
language and you're buying people shitty
gifts what a lazy ass way to show you
love
that's pity thank you thank you
all right but before we move on how many
people do we have left in line I can't
see a damn thing
there's at least four oh okay so I need
two of them to hang out I'm gonna
apologize to the other four because we
got we have to move on to another
segment the two people who were gonna be
remaining we'll get to you in a moment
all of you will get a hug you can rest
assured we we usually do the segment
called added-value where we talk about
something that has added value to our
lives recently and you know we used to
just recommend some sort of drake album
or something
and but we're here in Calgary so we're
going to talk about some local stuff
that has added value to our lives in
Calgary
wait am I going first Ryan what is added
value to your life while here in Calgary
oh man um first up life I love Calgary
like it's it's I don't know that people
are great man I don't know I just I
really love Calgary I love Canada for
the reason that a lot of a lot of
Canadian cities major huge Canadian
cities they they don't focus on a lot of
chain restaurants it's it's it's more
mom-and-pop like restaurants everywhere
I don't know if you've ever been to the
States but it's like no matter what city
you go to there's a couple Applebee's
and a couple TGI Fridays and a couple
Ruby Tuesday's and if you're in the
Midwest you got champs and Ryan I just
saw this article this octogenarian
couple who finally visited every Cracker
Barrel in the United States
congratulations
hashtag life goals hashtag blessed
[Applause]
um there uh we ate at a restaurant
earlier today all right so jess has the
most allergies I've ever known of of my
life food allergies God love her she's
mainly allergic to flavor Josh has the
second most allergies I have ever known
I'm allergic to fun I I'm trying this
like ketogenic thing with with Melbourne
to support him and I really like a lot
of the benefits that come from it so we
go to this restaurant and the the
waitress comes up and she's like hey can
I take your order and she just have a
pad of paper and I'm like I'm like
looking at Jessica this is gonna be so
we're gonna be like those guys at the
table like like who where did this word
of his pork come from we don't ask that
question I'm kidding she literally asked
is there pepper on the chicken so so
long story short they she went way out
of her way to take this huge long list
of an order with substitutes and I asked
her to get a notepad yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah Josh was like yeah thank God a yes
or like you know what we're sorry we're
gonna be really difficult but you might
want to write this down um but we went
to a dairy Lane cafe on 19th the food
was outstanding and like they actually
do they have a uni you don't have to ask
where it comes from because on the board
it's like hey this is we're gonna report
from this we're gonna be from which is
really really cool so I would totally
recommend that what do you got millions
yeah we've been here four times in the
last five years and every time I get
coffee here I didn't get a chance to do
it today because we've I just got in
from Vancouver so you better believe I'm
gonna go get some good coffee tomorrow
but Phil and Sebastian's is like amazing
although I've been told quite a bit on
the Twitter's that I need to go to a
place called monogram so so let's get
this vote here and you're gonna decide
where we go in the morning with a round
of applause yeah yeah so first Phil and
Sebastian's
[Applause]
alright and monogram well there you have
it so eg at Friday's it is if for those
of you listen to this if you're visiting
Calgary there's a couple of good
recommendations for you let's move on
real quick too right here right now so
we talk about what's going on the lives
the minimalist don't worry you all we'll
get to your questions in a moment and
we're in the middle of this tour if you
couldn't tell it's 40 cities all of
Canada is sold out so thank you Canada
for supporting the minimalist yeah a lot
of cities in the states are already sold
out as well some tickets left over at
les is now calm there's one city in
particular that isn't sold out it's
November 5th and it's in Houston now you
can imagine why that's not sold out and
there's a lot of troubling stuff
happening in the south right now I mean
Ryan and I own a coffee shop in Florida
and we just boarded it up yesterday we
didn't personally we were in Canada and
but it's I mean we're closed for the
next week all the staff is safe and we
want to make sure of that and and we
don't we have no idea what's gonna
happen to to Florida but what's going on
Houston right now if you've seen the
pictures it's total devastation over a
hundred thousand houses have been
affected by hurricane Harvey and we
wanted to help so for those of you
listening at home if you get a chance to
attend the event there November 5th 100%
of the profits go to the hurricane
Harvey relief fund we partnered up with
a charity called global giving and a
hundred percent of the money reaches the
ground there for two different things
one is immediate rescue relief and aid
which is really important but then to
the long-term rebuilding efforts it's
gonna take months ideally it's going to
its
take years to be honest to rebuild many
of these houses and so we wanted to help
but there are other ways that you can
help as well you can go to the
minimalists comm slash Harvey and you
can donate directly to GlobalGiving
doesn't even go through us we just send
you right over to to their website
[Applause]
no I just I've been looking for a time
to interject this story over the last
like three or four tour stops we've been
on but when when we were in we were
Toronto yeah we're are no no Montreal
okay yeah it was Montreal I think know
for sure cuz yeah Montreal I freaking
love Montreal has got this like Berlin
thing going on I just love it man it's
like yeah it's really really awesome
they all speak German what no with like
I mean yeah that's what I meant but
anyway I'm in Montreal we're gonna rego
on stage I get this like I'm sitting
there and I'm looking at Instagram I'm
like oh you have I always have these
like requested messages that I never pay
attention to because if I do then I feel
like at the answer them and it's it's
it's just a lot to like respond to you
know a million people if you're rounding
up to the nearest million so I just I
was sitting there and I'm like you know
what I'm at least gonna go through it
just to see if there's like any friends
trying to get ahold of me you know
whatever like browse through it yeah and
I get this I get he's gonna felt like a
really heartwarming story and I'm
stepping on I really do apologize I
[Laughter]
wouldn't have it any other way man know
so it's it's this message from all I saw
was you know something likes just
something really heartfelt like you have
no idea how much you know and then it's
like the ellipsis and I'm like alright
you got me
like I'm gonna you know click on it and
it was you have no idea how much this
means to me right now and then like I
pulled this picture and it's this woman
who's holding a copy of minimalism live
a meaningful life and she's ankle deep
in water in her house and
like that's why that's why we do this
like that is why Josh and I will go on
tour eight times in seven years that is
why we will leave our partners for a
little bit I mean we got really
supportive awesome partners but but that
right there is why Josh and I really go
out and do this but at the end of my
talk when I said we really want to add
value to all of your lives I really mean
that
and if it was just her that got
something out of it like it would make
the whole thing worthwhile so if you are
like us and you like to give back this
is a perfect opportunity for y'all to
tell about some some people who are
needed yes all the details everything I
just talked about the minimalists comm
slash Harvey we find all the ways you
can contribute even leave a review or
attend the event you can contribute
directly as well speaking of minimalism
live a meaningful life we have books out
there afterward but I don't want to try
to force any books onto anyone here so
if you came here you can't afford one
you didn't bring your wallet you just
want to steal one feel free we're happy
to buy you one you're welcome to buy one
as well 100% still it though that would
be awesome let's see just catch someone
stealing a book she's our strong arm
yeah so yeah we'll be out there
afterward about 20 minutes after the
event will dish out hugs and photos and
sign stuff as well one last thing on
right here right now is Ryan and I are
moving this month to Los Angeles because
that's where people go to tell stories
and we want to be able to continue to
tell our story and illuminate other
people's stories as well and the way
we're gonna do that is we're building a
podcast and film studio a lot of people
really resonated with our documentary
and so we want to do a lot more
meaningful video creations not content
creation I'm allergic to just creating
content for the sake of content that
word has been just bastardized and
stepped on and we want to do something
meaningful but we do need your help we
keep this podcast a hundred percent
advertisement free even though it's one
biggest podcasts in the world which is a
really odd thing to say every time I
have to say but you see five thousand
advertisements a day and I don't want it
to be five thousand plus another
mattress ad and a Squarespace ad and
whatever else is investing our our
podcast world these days I think it's
possible to do ads in a way that can add
value to people's lives but I think for
the most part they don't align with our
values and so we could use your help if
you want to become a supporter of the
minimalist podcast you can go to the
minimalists com click on the donate
thing at the top there are two ways to
support you can give a one-time donation
or you can contribute via something
called patreon we have over a thousand
people right now we're trying to get 1%
of our audience to become patrons and
that's gonna help us build a podcast in
film studio zero dollars goes to me or
Ryan and what we're we're using that
money for is to pay full-time producer
or full-time filmmaker and obviously pay
for the studio and all the equipment but
also we want to give something back to
you so we each week now we've been doing
a bonus overtime episode of the
minimalists podcast it shows up in your
podcast feed so if you listen on Apple
podcast or overcast or Google Play or
whatever you just get a separate feed so
you get the minimalist podcast but then
in addition to that you get the
minimalists private podcast straight
from patreon if you are a patreon
supporter and so right now Sean if you
can fade out somehow he will on the
audio and then we'll we'll go to this
private podcast and we'll be back to the
regularly scheduled program in a moment
and now Sean back to our regularly
scheduled podcast so while we're on the
road we have a tour manager we also have
a podcast producer we have a podcast
editor we have a website editor a book
editor we have
an all-around outstanding human being
operations manager the director of
operations for the minimalist the guy
behind the minimalism he does all of
this ladies and gentleman podcast Jean
is lurking in the shadows before we get
out of here I want to thank two other
people well one is an organization I
think the University of Calgary for
having us here tonight let's give them a
round of applause and most important oh
by the way if if you do get a book
tonight out there please minimize it
afterward you know just you can pass it
on to a friend family member
arch-nemesis someone else it won't do it
you any good collecting dust on on a
shelf anyway I do want to think one
other person in that person is you Ryan
and I are really grateful you decided to
spend some time with us here tonight you
cost you money to get in here which
allows us to pay Sean and pay chess and
actually sleep on a bed instead of
someone's floor or a rest stop which is
what our old plan was it allows us to
travel here pay for security and staff
at the venue pay for the venue and you
also gave up two of your most precious
resources though you gave up your time
and your attention and we're really
grateful for that and if you leave here
with just one message tonight we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for being here y'all thank you
Calgary thank you so much
[Applause]
hi this is crystal calling from Seattle
and I had two suggestions based on
recent podcasts the first one was
regarding getting rid of social media on
your phone and I have uninstalled
Instagram though I still have an account
it's the only social media platform I
use so what I've done instead of
compulsive compulsively checking it
every single time I pick up my phone is
I've uninstalled it and I check it on my
desktop before and after I start my work
before I start my workday and as I end I
have found that also there's no ads that
come through when you check on desktop
and although the usability isn't as
robust as it is at the app it's still a
great way to look at cat pictures and
everything else you want to say on
Instagram my second and tip was for the
woman who said the Eclipse glasses were
weighing her down I ran into somebody
who lives in an area where they're
having a solar eclipse in a year or two
and has family that are still there and
she was looking to collect Eclipse
glasses that people had already used so
she could avoid spending the money on
them in the future and also avoid
sending the existing ones to the
landfill so those in the US probably
won't hang on to them so I might
recommend looking to figure out when the
next eclipses are and maybe reaching out
to communities in those areas to see if
there's some sort of an exchange and to
divert those from the landfill but also
find a great way to get rid of them fear
not hanging onto them
hello my name is Dario I'm from Holly
Springs North Carolina I'm running
errands this morning and I'm listening
to episode 99 that the podcast called
breathe and I literally pulled over put
the car into park because I had a
comment for Sophie who feels judged and
questioned by those around her about her
choices and she's tired of constantly
explaining herself I think part of the
reason you may be feeling judged and you
may be questioned is because you're
holding up a mirror to these people and
sometimes what they're seeing is a bit
uncomfortable you know they may be in
their mind and heart questioning am I
too much am i spending time on things
that don't matter and so people like
comfort is the minimalists always say
and so part of the reason they might be
questioning you and judging you is
because they want you to go back to
their side and read and reaffirm and
affirm their choices so I my advice to
you would be be the statue to stand firm
and in your difference and maybe in the
future you will you will show the other
people the light hi Josh and Ryan my
name is Jeffrey and I live in Anchorage
Alaska I just wanted to share a short
story with you guys that relates to the
idea that instead of trying to convert
people people will recognize the
benefits of your lifestyle over the past
year I've been trying to rid my life is
clutter and focus on what's most
important to me throughout this time of
use various phrases along the lines of
having life stuff helps me be more
creative or having less stuff just gives
me more freedom and other similar
phrases I had never once told anyone
that quote I'm a minimalist nor have I
even used the word minimalist but just
the other day my friend came up to me
and said hey I checked out that
minimalist thing of yours it's pretty
interesting and he said he was excited
to try some of the ideas oh I recall
your answers to the questions of how do
I make my loved ones become minimalist I
felt this story perfectly encompassed
the idea that people will notice the
benefits of your intentional living
you won't need to force your lifestyle
or your ideas on people notice the
people close to you try to point their
lives where they're late for growth
still actively seek out what benefits
they are seeing in your own life
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got ahead
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I bet
that you'll be fine without your team
[Music]
you
[Music]